le commerce est l'école de la tromperie
disait luc de clapiers un philosophe qui
avait vu juste au xviiie siècle l'image
du couteau dans le dos apparaît comme
évidente mais la question qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui c'est comment la france en
est arrivé là le sénat s'interroge à
juste titre et a demandé lundi la
création d'une commission d' enquête
sénatoriale sur les conditions de la
rupture de ce contrat et ses
conséquences sur le plan industriel et
stratégique
un contrat de ce montant là ne se des
boucles pas en une nuit j'ai un peu de
mal à comprendre comment cela s'est
passé je ne suis pas la seule cela pose
quelques questions sur nos services qui
n'ont pas vu se lier une alliance entre
les américains les australiens et les
britanniques oui car l'acte symbolique
du rappel des ambassadeurs aux états
unis et en australie ne règle pas les
problèmes de fond l'opposition politique
n'a d'ailleurs pas manqué de signaler le
laxisme des manuels macron vis-à-vis à
joe biden jean luc mélenchon dénonce une
capitulation sans condition et parle
d'humiliation marine le pen la
présidente du rassemblement national
ironise sur la défense de la fierté de
la france par le chef de l'état
damien abad le chef de file des
républicains à l'assemblée parle d'un
revers diplomatique consternant qui
accentuent leurs faiblesses de
l'influencent hexagonal dans le monde
car les conséquences diplomatiques pour
paris sont réels et de nombreux
politiques comme valérie pécresse
s'interroge sur la possibilité d'une
sortie de la france du commandement
intégré de l'otan en représailles
l'occasion pour emmanuel macron de
souhaiter une nouvelle fois une
hypothétique défense européenne dans les
faits c'est beaucoup plus compliqué ne
serait-ce qu'au regard des budgets
militaires respectifs 730 milliards
d'euros pour les états unis 230
seulement pour l'europe l'écart est
impressionnant et laisse très peu de
marge de manoeuvre sans même évoquer la
difficulté à coordonner une alliance
militaire rassemblant des pays parfois
loin du consensus politique seulement
lire une différence colossale en matière
de lieu mais également
l'homme comme on tient dans lequel
l'europe elle-même
les intérêts stratégiques des divers
états sont extrêmement divers donc pour
les supprimer tous dans un ensemble il
faudrait un budget extrêmement important
et avons mis au goût très bien chez lui
on peut très bien aller
vers la thèse selon laquelle cette idée
française de défense européenne et d'une
chimère le soutien bien tardif apporté
par l'union européenne à paris illustre
bien la réticence européenne à se fâcher
avec son vieil allié peu de solutions
s'offrent à la france qui ne peut seul
envisager une confrontation avec les
états unis le constat est clair l'oncle
sam privilégiera toujours ses propres
intérêts d'un point de vue économique
comme géostratégique au delà des
déclarations d'amour enflammées
prononcés ces derniers jours par la
diplomatie américaine la france ne
semble guère valoir plus à ses yeux
qu'une simple variable d'ajustement